so we talked a bunch about politics well
one of the other interesting things is
that you're involved with is uh
or involved with defining the future of
is journalism
i suppose you can think of podcasts as a
kind of journalism of course
but also just writing in general just
whatever the hell the future of this
thing looks like
uh is up to be defined by people like
you
so what do you think is broken about
journalism and what do you think is the
future of journalism
i think the future of journalism looks
much more like
what we and i are doing here right now
and
journalism is going to be downstream
from a culture that can be a good and a
bad thing depending on how you look at
it
we are going to look at our media our
media is going to look
much more like it did pre-mass media
and the way that i mean that is that
back in the 18
in the 1800s in particular especially
after the invention of the telegraph
when
information itself was known so for
example like
you and i don't need to let's say you
and i are competing journalists
you and i are no longer competing quote
unquote to tell the public
x event happened all journalism
today is largely explaining
why did x happen and part of the problem
with that
is that that means that it's all up for
partisan interpretation now you can say
that that's a bad thing
i think it's a great thing because the
highest level of literacy
and news viewership in america
was during the time of yellow journalism
was during the time of partisan
journalism
not a surprise people like to really
read the news
from people that they agree with you
could say that's bad echo chambers
etc that's the downside of it the upside
is more people are more educated
more people are interested in the news
so i think the proliferation of mass
media i mean sorry of this format
of long form of not just long form
dude i do i do updates on instagram
which are five minutes oh you consider
like
instagram yeah almost even twitter oh of
course twitter
twitter is where i get my news from i
don't read the paper i have literally
twitter is my news aggregator it's
called my wire where i find out about
hard events like the president
has departed the white house but not
only like that i don't know about you
but for i also looked at twitter
to the exact thing you're saying which
is the response to the news like
the thoughtful sounds ridiculous but you
can be pretty thoughtful in a single
tweet if you fi
if you follow the right people yeah you
can get that and so
that is the future of media which is
that the future of media
is it will be much smaller amount
or much larger amounts of people which
are famous to smaller groups
so walter cronkite's never going to
happen again at least in our
probably within our lifetimes where
everybody in america know who's this guy
is
that that age is over i think that's a
good thing because
now people are going to get the news
from the people that they trust
yes some of it will be opinionated i'm
going to my my program
i'm crystal and i are like we are this
she's coming from this like view i'm
coming from this view
that's our bias when we talk about
information and we're going to talk
about the information
that we think is important and it has
garnered a large audience
i think that's very much where the
future is going to be
and the reason why i think that's a good
thing is because
people will be engaged more within it
rather than the current system
where news is highly concentrated highly
consolidated
has group think has the same elite
production pipeline problem of
everybody knows journalists all come
from the same socioeconomic background
and they all party together here in dc
or in new york or in la
or wherever and there's part of the same
monoculture and that affects what they
uh that affects what they report this
will cause a total dispersion
of all of that the the a the battle of
our age
is going to be the guild versus the
non-guild so
like what we see right now with the new
york times and clubhouse
this is a very very very very very
intentional
thing that is happening which is that
the times
talking about unfettered conversations
that's
happening on clubhouse for people who
aren't aware this is important because
they need to be the fetterers of
conversation
they need to be the inter-agent that's
where they get their power they get
their power
from convincing facebook that they are
the ones who can fact
check stuff they are the ones who can
tell you whether something is right
or wrong that battle over
unimpeded conversation and the explosion
of a format that you and i are doing
really well in
and then this more consolidated one
which holds cultural power
and elite power and more importantly
money right over you and i
that's the battle that we're all gonna
do do you think unfettered conversations
have a chance to win this battle
yes i do in the long run in the long run
the internet is simply too powerful
but here's the mistake everybody makes
the new york times will never lose
it will just become one of us see you
think so they already are
they're the largest daily the daily look
at the daily
not even that think about it not in
podcasting the times
is not a mass media product it
is a subscription product for upper
middle class
largely white liberals who live the same
circumstances
across the united states and in europe
there's nothing wrong with that
but here's the thing you can't be the
paper of record when you're actually
the paper of upper middle class white
america your job
is to report on the news from that angle
and deliver them the product that they
want
there's nothing wrong with that their
stock price is higher than ever
they're making 10 times more money than
they did 10 years ago
but it comes at the cost of not having a
mass
application audience so like when people
i think people in our space
are always like the new york times gonna
be destroyed no it's actually even
better
they will just become one of us they
already are their subscription platform
well yes in terms of the actual
mechanism but you know
uh new york times is still and i don't
think i'm speaking about a particular
sector i think it as a brand
it is it does have the level of
credibility assigned to it still
you know there's politization of it
totally
but if there's a credibility like it has
much more credibility than
i forgive me than i think you and i have
no you're right in in terms of uh your
podcast like people are not going to be
like
uh they're going to cite the new york
times versus what you said on the
podcast
for uh for an opinion
that i wonder in the sense of battles
whether unfettered conversations whether
joe rogan whether
your podcast can become the
have the same level of legitimacy or the
the flip side
new york times loses the legitimacy to
be at the same level
of uh in terms of how we talk about it
it's getting long it's a long battle
right it's going to take a long time and
i'm saying this is where i think the end
state is going
and look at what the times is doing
they're leaning into podcasting for a
reason
but not just podcasting as in
npr level like here's what's happening
michael barbaro is a celebrity
right the guy who does the daily yeah
that guy's famous
amongst these people cause they're like
oh my god i love michael like i love the
way he does this stuff
again that's fine more people are
listening to the news i think that's a
good thing
yeah and then who else do they hire ezra
klein from vox
yeah kara swisher also from box who does
pivot which is an amazing podcast
um or uh jane coston same thing it's
personalities
who are becoming bundled together within
this brand
right here's yeah okay maybe i'm just a
hater
[Laughter]
because i loved podcasting from the
beginning i loved green day before the
record
man but i am bothered by it like why
doesn't karis wish her she's done
successfully i think i know
oh no she was always a part of some kind
of institution i'm not sure
but she started her own thing i think it
would
recode right yeah the recode i don't
know if that's her own thing yeah yeah
so
she was very successful there why the
hell did she join the new york times
with the new podcast
why is michael barbaro not do his own
thing
because he gets paid and because he has
he wants the elite cachet
that you just referenced within his
social circle in new york which is that
i think the biggest mistake
that some of the venture people make is
if we give everybody the tools
that those people are all going to leave
to like go sub sack and go independent
within their social circle sacrificing
some money from being independent is
worth it to be a part of the new york
times
that's sad to me because it propagates
old thinking like you know it propagates
old institutions
and you could say that new york times is
going to evolve quickly and so on but
i would love it if there was a mechanism
for re-establishing like for building
new new york times
in terms of public legitimacy and i
suppose that's
wishful thinking because it takes time
to
build trust in institutions and it takes
time to build new institutions my main
thing i would say is public legitimacy
as a concept is not going to be there in
mass media anymore
because of the balkanization of
audiences i mean think about it right
like
um this is like legion you know the
classic stuff around a thousand true
fans or
no sorry like a hundred true fans even
now like you can make a living on the
internet just talking to a hundred
people
yeah if as long as they're all high
frequency traders some of the highest
people
pay people on sub stack they don't have
that many subs
it's just that they're wall street guys
right so people pay a lot of money again
that's great so what you will have is an
increasing
balkanization of the internet of
audiences and of niches
people will become increasingly famous
within us you will become
astoundingly famous i'm sure you've
noticed this with your fan base i just
certainly have with mine like
99 of people have no idea who i am but
when somebody meet they're like oh my
god
i watch your show every day right looks
the only thing
watching for news right like instead of
casually famous
if that makes sense like oh yeah it's
like alec baldwin yeah you know yeah oh
that solid ball but you're not like
oh
i love you alec baldwin it's this is a
ben smith
of the new york times actually he wrote
this column he's like the future is
everybody will be famous
but only to a small group of people and
i think that is true
but again i don't decry it i think it's
great because i think that the more
that that happens the more engaged
people will be and it empowers
different voices to be able to come in
and then possibly i wouldn't say destroy
but compete
you